what up guys after my bodybuilding show
this year I've been able to maintain my
body weight at low 180s which is where I
want cuz that's what I'm going to
compete at in powerlifting next year and
I feel like 180s is like my most Ideal
Balance between strength but also size
also athleticism and cardio my strongest
is usually for sure like 190 195 but
then I lose out on a lot of cardio I'm
not able to do um BJJ rounds back to
back I can't just run 3 to 5 miles
whenever I want and then when I'm in my
high 170s I'm super lean I look super
good but I'm not very strong so being in
my low 180s is my allaround favorite and
I've been able to maintain a pretty good
low 180 body weight after my
bodybuilding show in August so that's
August September October November so 4
months and then um when Thanksgiving
came around I was like you know what
I'mma just let it go I don't want to
have to worry about anything I'mma just
eat the way I want all the way until
Christmas and see what happens so I woke
up today and this is like a few days
after Christmas and I was
194 so I gained 10 lb in 1 month and I'm
like holy smok soz I thought I was going
to go maybe High 180s I didn't think I
was going to break into like the mid
190s thank God I didn't hit 200 but
anyways since it is the new year now um
I want to set myself up for Success so
today I'm going to be meal prepping cuz
the majority of success lies in the
preparation right have you guys heard of
that story where they go they ask Abe
Lincoln if I gave you 4 hours to cut
down a tree how would you spend it and
he said I spend 3 hours sharpening the
YX 1 hour cutting down the tree so
that's how important preparation is
because with the blunt axe it might take
you 8 hours to knock it down right so I
got some stuff from Costco just like
really simple stuff and I noticed if I
make things too fancy or if the barrier
of Entry is too high I'm just not going
to get it done so I got something simple
Normandy Style vegetable blend I just
throw garlic Sal on this some chicken
bullan and it tastes bomb I got myself
some USDA Choice cerin steaks by the way
the steaks from Costco are I don't know
if I should have kissed my fingers just
touching meat anyways I got some sirloin
steaks and then I'm about to make some
white rice and for my dessert
dude this thing is insane I don't know
what it is about the Costco 3 berry
blend I buy Berry Blends from Alberton
RS everywhere and they're all kind of
flavorless and after I throw the berries
in I always feel like I got to add um
like sugar or honey to make the flavor
pop but with this I can eat it just by
itself out of a bowl and it tastes like
I'm eating a Popsicle so that keep keeps
a super low calories and I get my sweet
tooth fix and I'm just talking about my
mouth watering and and not because I'm
fat and I also got these fire roasted
vegetables got a bunch of these bad boys
got some
chicken since uh I am easing into the
diet I'm going keep it simple first and
uh start with the red meat
although if I was a good boy I would
like to go harsh first and start with
the chicken and then use the red meat as
a dessert later on in the week
but through the process of instacarting
they did rip my thing so I'm using this
as an excuse to well better cook these
bad boys
now first things
first got to wash the rice I like making
the rice cuz our rice cooker is that
Japanese one and it takes a minute like
30 to 45 minutes so I like having this
just cooked in the
background and I'm making about 3 cups
rice and that should be enough for my
meal prep um and for the family
too and usually like if it was for looks
like if I'm just going straight just
trying to get lean I would probably go
my first week or two only meat and
veggies and you'll see a drastic
difference in your weight loss but
because um I'm going to be entering the
powerlifting circuit
competitively this year high intensity
workouts highly um rely on having
carbs so I'll have a little bit of carbs
with each meal maybe even a half a cup
something tiny just to make sure I'm
still fueled through my
workouts so that uh I can push myself
really really hard cuz that's the
difference between powerlifting and
bodybuilding like with bodybuilding it
doesn't really matter how strong you are
right it just mean you just need to see
how ripped you are but powerlifting it's
like how much can you lift at at that
weight so because of that I need to make
sure it still got power and that's the
biggest difference but the cool part is
with my new added bodybuilding prep and
my tool belt I have so many more tools
that I can use now in my powerlifting
Journey which I'm really really really
excited about and uh we have a big
announcement on the barber Brigade
YouTube channel so you should for sure
check that out and yes I just did the
Asian measurement to see how much water
to put in and it's always that first
[Music]
crease see 45 minutes T's going to take
I should probably how these vents face
outwards cuz it starts steaming and I
don't want it to cause any like damage
in the cabinets but there looks kind of
risky but that'll work now comes the fun
part I was actually going to season the
steaks first but then
I realized I need my grill to be piping
hot and I need to burn off all the gunk
that was on there from the last time I
cooked so I'm going to turn this bad boy
on and man having a gas grill is so
convenient cuz you don't have to deal
with all the charcoal mess like this uh
Grill system is connected straight into
the gas system of the house so it turns
on just like the stove inside of my
house which has made grilling so much
more fun so much easier it is lacking
that smokey flavor but it's just enough
you know it's just enough where I'm down
to do it consistently cuz the other one
is such a pain in the ass it makes me
not want to do it that often cuz I have
to wash my hands and do all this and
then after the charcoal is piping hot I
got to figure out way dispose of the
charcoal so for me these days if I want
repetitive actions it's always lower the
barrier entry so I'm going to turn that
on for like a good 20 minutes to really
burn off all the gunk hey Google 20
minute
timer sure 20 minutes and we're starting
now now it's time to season the
meat so when it comes to seasoning the
meat um I like to do something
simple and uh I like salt pepper black
pepper of course what what am I talking
about salt pepper um onion powder and
garlic but with beef especially when I'm
going with a leaner cut like a sirloin
to bring out the beefiness I like using
onion powder so I would say I probably
use more onion than garlic if you want
to go by ratios so yeah I'm real
generous with the onion cuz I feel like
it really brings out the beefiness since
it doesn't have the fat to bring that
out you know and then also the way that
I like to season it is just in case I
need to like uh multi-purpose use it in
like a Asian dish or a middle eastern
dish or American dish these are some
basic seasonings that can be quite
adaptable put that bad boy on black
pepper there we
go
there flip these bad boys over try to
pick up the see this is the dope part
about Costco it's really hard to get
these nice fatty Cuts not fatty as in
like fat content but like thick cuts um
at regular supermarkets I just don't
think they're Birch butchers are capable
of this but I like it because the way
you're able to cook
these I'm just my mouth is watering it's
just so juicy so even though I'm getting
sirloin which is pretty
lean it's going to be tasty and moist
almost like a New York but with like
half the
fat so I can still get my red meat fixed
and the good thing is with
powerlifting unlike bodybuilding you
need to get like dick skin I don't need
to get dick
skin I just need to get lean enough to
be in my weight class and not car be
around too much extra
fat so I don't have to be that stringent
you know the only time I would have to
go chicken breast or whatever is if I'm
trying to squeeze a bunch of other
things into my diet like ice cream or
whatever then yeah then maybe that day
I'll go a ton chicken breast so I stay
super lean on one end hit ice cream on
the other end then overall day balance
is somewhere in the middle but for the
most part that's why I even cover my
desserts with like those berries cuz
then I'm like I don't even need ice
cream I'm good I got my sweet tooth
cover I got
my uh rice cakes you know what I'm
saying I got my chocolate rice cakes got
my fair life milk I'm
good bam
done
de's so next step is cooking the veggies
and you might be asking bro are you
about to cook veggies in a pot yes I am
so usually if I'm just cooking for like
one or two meals I like to pan that
[__] you know what I'm saying
but I'm trying to cook in bulk cuz I
want to make my life as easy as possible
so I got water up to like halfway you
see that so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to boil it and then once it's
boiling I throw these big old bag of
veggies in there and my secret sauce is
this that makes it taste good get
yourself some authentic chicken bullan
for some reason it's hard to find these
like this big size at a normal uh
grocery store you got to go to the Latin
grocery stores but you put couple
spoonfuls of this in
there and you almost don't even need
anything else but I'll boil it in here
when I'm done put a dash of like garlic
salt on there and boom it's going to be
ready to go this is going to be very
tasty and one of my favorite things
about meal prepping honestly is just the
whole family gets
to benefit like everyone gets high
protein meal low fat meal low Gunk you
know and it makes me happy like low
processed low preservatives cuz look
even on this bag it says says no
preservatives see that Whole Foods baby
that's the whole point your goal is to
eat as little
foods that doesn't expire as possible
like your good food will expire without
a fridge that's how you know food is
actually good everything in this Pantry
even though it's delicious like the fact
that these peanut butter cups oh my God
it's so dark the fact that these peanut
butter cups can sit here for like two
months nothing happens to it that's a
problem the fact that the these muffins
can stay here for 2
months that's a problem these Milano
cookies all these are problems including
that the udon you
know including my beloved chocolate rice
cakes when I'm meal prepping time is of
the essence I'm trying to get everything
done as fast as I can to be efficient
with time that's the whole point of meal
prepping right so in between the grill
being ready and the water being boiling
I'm setting up the next step which is
having all the meal preps out I have a
feeling that won't even contain all of
it so I might have to get these bad boys
out just for the rice that's left over
which is a good thing cuz that means the
family gets to eat for the week like
have extra food for the week and they
don't have to worry about it versus
postmating or or cooking any process
foods and probably this
for the extra meat I have a feeling the
veggies this is is not that big of a pot
I think the veggies will be evenly
divided in
here see what I'm
saying it comes up so always got to move
it I'm just paranoid I don't know if
it'll actually affect it but I just feel
like it will so I just move it to the
side you'll move the side leave a little
more just in
case so I'm just going to eyeball this
just considering how much water's in
here
and that looks like it should be good
we're not trying to fully flavor the
veggies with this it's just to add like
a base line of flavor and then I could
add um garlic salt hey Google stop so
that's perfect timing now it's time for
me to go outside to the grill clean that
bad boy and get ready to throw the meat
on so I dumped the veggies in there I
was able to dump almost like half the
back which is a lot of veggie meal prep
which is
awesome and
now get to place this lid and once I
reach a second boil that's when the
veggies are done I'll probably just so
it's like slightly a little bit alente
I'll probably like take them out before
it even reaches the second
boil all
right so this thing is hot it's been
going on for a good 20 minutes scrub
these bad boys
off see the
flames on the
bristles I don't know if that's a good
thing might not actually be a good thing
to be honest
but it might have to get a new
brush it's hot though I can feel it on
my
forehead note to
self woo next time go to
Lowe's get a new
brush and get one that's a wire
brush cuz that bad boy is
gonzo
now here's a wet paper
towel wipe off any of the
extra
S I personally don't like wiping too
much of it off so that's actually like
half the grill flavor too like if you
ever eat from like a brand new grill
actually doesn't tast it it's not what
you would call like
seasoned like even brand new walks you
want something that has past memories on
there
that's a nice and hot
baby okay there we
go looks good enough to
me throw these bad boys on
[Music]
there
dude I could have cooked all the chicken
too I just realized forgot how big this
Grill
is
okay turn this side off then I don't
need
it glad I was able to clean that side
though cover it for 3 minutes see what
happens oo actually I see a little flame
right there see that
flame think it's like burning old oil
yeah that's not going to be good to
cover for 3 minutes cuz by the time I
come back who knows what this looks
like might have to move this back way
over
here what's going on little bit bro
don't be burning my
steaks all right so I had uh the steaks
covered for about what the okay there we
go for 3 minutes on on a medium let see
how they
look oo not too bad a little bit burnt
learning this Grill as I
go not too bad
actually next time I'll come out in 2
minutes this one's actually pretty
good considering how big they are it is
going to cook a little bit uneven
but we doing this fast no way I could do
this in a pan with these big
boys
set this right
here so I'll probably turn it down just
a little bit more so it's at a medium
maybe like medium low medium low medium
low and then I'll set it for another 3
minutes now maybe 2 and A2 minutes to be
sure but look at that I can see the
juiciness coming
out about to get these bad boys
perfectly medium
rare all right so I took two precautions
this time lowered it to medium low and
also set a 2 and 1/2 Minute Timer let's
see what the damage looks like oh much
better okay so that's a sweet spot
medium low
and um 2 and 1/2 minute better move this
bad boy move over here let see it's
looking good though looking good at
least one size
presentable so
I'm not a science type of guy when it
comes to grilling I'm more of like a
feel so just by the feel I think it
could go for another good like 2 minutes
maybe but just on
low so put on low
low
low and I think 2 minutes should be good
right now it might just be
rare especially this bad boy boys thick
you know what I'm
saying I'll make sure I don't flip them
over though yep keep keep the ugly side
up for
now so that we at least have one pretty
side but by the time we chop it up you
won't even
tell got 2
minutes meanwhile when I came inside to
cut the I mean to wash The Cutting Board
I realized the water was boiling so I
have to blanch the veggies real quick
which just means you just throw I mean
not blanch um what's the word I don't
know these scientific words or sh blanch
I have to blanch him real quick mobra is
not feeling good but she will not jump
on the opportunity to correct me any you
son of a any anyways I threw some cold
water on there I I hate you so much
that's the only strength I have left but
I want you to know that I hate you I I
hate you too don't
so yeah thre some cold water on there
cuz then if it remains it in its own
juices and temp it'll keep cooking it'll
get soggy so we don't want that like
your meter let's see how it tastes M
pretty good so I'll season it this is
done this is done
woohoo getting close to start plating
everything which is very very
cool you know what I might do oh boy
it's hot I might just season it right
here you know what I'm saying play all
right right before I was going to season
the
veggies my alarm for the grill went off
so definitely don't want to mess that
up looking nice and
juicy okay so let's move them off the
grill here's my little trick flip them
upside down so it looks
perfect no one has to know right here
boom look at
that take these bad boys Oho look at
that probably cut this piece last it's
so
fat and here we
go there now turn off the
grill everything's turned off just
double check off off off off
yep and you want to let meat rest you
don't want to just cut it right away cuz
that's when all the juic is going to
come out I'm probably going to give
these bad boys it look kind of thick
might give these bad boys like a good 7
minutes before I cut them so it could
reabsorb all its
juices so it's uh 57 right now 124 cut
them all right time to season the
veggies I think I'm going to use these
uh everything but the El
cuz it has salt chili pepper Chipotle
cumin give it a nice little kick you
know what I'm saying so just Dash it up
like that you feel
me and
then mixy
mixy wo
careful mixy
mixy and then some garlic
up that should be pretty good veggies
cuz we got the chicken boan you know
what I'm
saying and then we got the Chipotle
chip and then we got
the
garos the veggies are a little bit more
cooked than I like cuz I like being able
to run my fingers through its hair
without it falling apart but this what
happens when
you're multitasking and literally doing
every single thing in the house [__] off
pretty good not bad for someone doing
every single thing in the
house I hope you
choke you guys hear that Gremlin back
there choke choke
that a little bit of
that there we go this going to taste
good
there we go mixy
mixy run my fingers through your hair
you know what I'm
saying mixy
mixy okay taste test
again M just right here we
go all right now it's time to Plate the
rice
all right now it's time to Plate the
rice what I'm looking for is about half
a cup which is about 100
G
so since I'm not like EMB body body
building prep what I'm going to do is I
do one where it's measured and then I
can eyeball the rest so let's
see 74
G
93 bam cool so it's pretty much
about 2 in
wide and about 6 in long you know what
I'm
saying why you laughing you crazy you're
so
stupid you're
me welcome to my cooking
[Applause]
show I hate you so much F I hate you
too
when do I start measuring again when I
hit a
plateau then what I do is I change the
adjustment so I'll probably go like 100
G to like 75 G or something like that
and I'll keep ballparking and then my
weight starts going up or not going back
down then I have to measure so usually
your precision and accuracy is dependent
on your goal so if you're like 300 lb
and you're trying to lose 10 lbs you
probably don't need to measure too much
stuff you just need to cut the
McDonald's out you know what I'm saying
but if you're like
appealed 170 and you're trying to get to
like
155 oh you better measure every single
thing that means it's time to cut the
meat so I got six of these meals lined
up got a bunch of rice left over which
is cool you could use that for other
stuff and if like Jill's going to split
one of these with Tao she could always
add extra rice to the mix and I don't
know how Jill's hair even got in here
that's weird cuz she's not even here
which means she didn't do a good job of
washing the dishes but
no leave me alone I don't feel
good all right now for the Moment of
Truth as I still try to figure out this
Grill
situation cuz I'm still not a master of
it but it'll be way easier to master
than uh charcoal grill cuz I can
straight up just control it you know
versus charcoal it's like ah it's
burning what do I do oh dump everything
out you know it's like harder a
troubleshoot but
okay let's cut let's cut this W there's
lots of juices coming up holy smokes
might be more
to I'm just bring this whole bad boy
over
cuz there's a ton of
juices and I don't want to get all over
the
place okay here let's do the
honors ooh that's soft
ooh ooh damn for a
cin ooh Dam I don't know if this is
Costco if if it's me cuz as you guys
know sirloin
is
not a very soft cut like a New York or
Porter House or a T-bone or ribeye you
know what I'm
saying it's this uh the one of the
thinner ones is a little bit more medium
still pink but not
red so what I would probably do is I'll
eat this today and the rarest pieces I
like meal prepping those cuz you have to
put them in the microwave anyways so a
lot of times when you put the rarer
pieces in there it actually comes out
perfect with the
microwave and I get the luxury
of the chef
bite oh that crust is
good okay okay
let see what we're working
with I thought I was going to need to
season it some more cuz some of was so
thick but so far so
good now I'm going to cut the fattest
piece so I can kind of take the average
of the
for some reason I have this urge want to
splash some lemon on
it I don't know why do you want me to
splash some lemon on the steak babe no
okay the evil witch has
spoken I just feel like you would
just why wait why didn't you Splash it
on your own
cuz I'm meal prepping
babe this is what but that's what you're
craving now why don't you do it doesn't
matter this is what socialism is okay
you pick one thing everyone does it you
guys like
socialist
governments well welcome to socialist
government your breath smells yes if
it's a socialist government one person
has breath smells everyone has a breath
smell oh wow look at that tenderness oh
damn what is this like a f man
fet dude look at this look at these the
bigger fatter ones yeah bigger
fatter now I want a pie you sold
me okay so when it's
thicker we going to need to season it a
little bit because the thickness in the
middle
but
juicy
especially for a sirloin
too season these
guys
theaa
just a little bit you know what I'm
saying it's a little a little something
something it's a little
something this a little something
something you know what I'm saying it's
a little
[Music]
Dash
all right since the sick lady wants some
here you
go keep in mind it's cin okay what does
that mean it's the leanest cut so it's
the healthiest so it's not like a riy or
New
York what is that m is it good mhm yeah
it's a lean
cut you want some of course she wants
them and Bam just like that we're done
here are six meal preps so if you were
single this would be six lunches right
there and each one has about half a cup
of rice I got about 6 to 8 O of sirloin
veggies and I got some leftover so we'll
eat this right now as our lunch so
technically probably would have came out
to like I think like eight
meals which is pretty good but yeah I'm
close these guys seal in the
freshness and that's going to
be my meals and the family's meals for
about a week and hopefully my weight
starts coming down not hopefully I know
it will cuz it's part of the plan
but thank you for watching me meal prep
this is my meal prep Vlog if You' like
to see other recipes let me know um I'd
love to share them with you but this is
a very simple one and I miss the flavor
of the grill like I love my Trifecta
meal prep cuz they keep it simple ship
it in a box throw it in the microwave
and when I'm in a rush Bam Bam Bam it's
my favorite go-to thing I travel with it
all the time but sometimes I just want
like Grill flavor and that homecooked
meal taste so I'll do a combination of
these two like I'll eat my diced chicken
and then I might have this as like a
dinner or something you know it's all
about balance to achieve what you want